[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur technik heute
gibt es einen gleich voll und zwar habe
ich eine kuh schnitte gemacht also
natürlich steckt da keine krawatte mit
sehen aus wie kleine kühe auf der weide
danny kleines risiko flecken drauf der
kuchen boden also der kuchen und das
steht auf einem schokoladenkuchen und
oben brauche ich eine leckere milch
geben
und ja ich finde das super einfacher
kuchen oder eine einfache schnitte
selber gesagt gibt es einen blechkuchen
und es wird weniger arbeiten und ich
starte jetzt gleich mit demokratie und
zeigen euch mal eben für den teig
brauche ich zwei eier bei effektiv vom
sofa etwas vanille exakt um einen
pflegefall 80 milliliter 100 milliliter
wasser hätte ich 200 familien jetzt
nicht von kakaopulver zwei teelöffel
backpulver der teig da ist schnell
zusammen gehört gebe die feier weigerung
entwicklung und wartung übrig habe die
frau später für die minister wegen vor
wenn ich immer gern mit dem teig kann
nicht einfach erhöht werden
damit fallen
und klar und die zutaten werden jetzt
für etwas finden
erstaunlich ist wie supermodels db2
niedriger stufe die beiden flüssigkeiten
also wasser und öl hinein
[Musik]
die rechtlichen fragen werden jetzt auf
die gäste
backpulver und cacau nein und gute
zutaten beim ganz kurzen schneebesen
unter
[Musik]
und meine vorbereitete form die habe ich
bereits auf 25 95 cm eingestellt und da
streift ihn gefragt warum lacht und für
die klasse weil wir alle ganz dahinten
einmal rundum blick
[Musik]
der kuchen wird es im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 15 minuten gepackt ich werde
die stäbchen vorbereiten und ihnen sagen
dann abkühlen lassen
der kubus abgefüllt jetzt geht es weiter
mit der kleben und bei der creme nämlich
ist eine mit creme und zwar besteht wir
dann auch milch quark und auf
sahneschnittchen wenig später ich zeige
euch noch gute zutaten für die
ministerien brausch 500 milliliter milch
zweiten acker etwas meine lee gefragt
was los
sonys bei einer krise fertig vom foto
figge 200 milliliter schlagsahne zwei
teelöffel seiner partei eine 15 watt und
von bestreichen spuren für den stoff
zwei entwürfe marmeladen zu erfahren
nämlich jetzt ist gaga das gebe ich hier
in einen topf da kommt 200 milliliter
vermittler da muss die mischung
aufkochen und zwei minuten lang sport
und hoffen damit die amazone eben auch
wirken kann und wie in einem separaten
topf erhitzen war verbaut und schreibe
ich einen kleinen dorf mit opfer finden
lassen wie er eine metallschüssel da
kommt das eiweiß sein
wie gesagt habe ich eben schon mit dazu
gegeben und puderzucker
fröhlich gesetzt schön
mit leitete auch hier das wasser im topf
brauchen und werden das eiweiß sozusagen
erhielten aber hier muss man jetzt immer
die ganze zeit mit dabei bleiben
wenn ich aufhöre zu rühren und freunde
finden
[Musik]
sobald das wasser kocht
noch eine minute lang erlebten dann zum
wasser barcelona
im kanton stellt 4 1 führen müssen und
wollten wir diesen so lange bis ein was
schreib und auf schalke
[Musik]
das ak habe ich jetzt etwa eine minute
abkühlen lassen
da kommt jetzt der honig mit rein und
man kann sich nämlich nach honig in dem
warmen arteaga gut aufhören
[Musik]
vanille und honig thomas fröhlich wir
langsamste fuß
mit max so langsam wie die attraktive
chance weg wird
[Musik]
und wenn die milch doch total war ohne
es leicht blog könnt ihr einfach noch
mal kurz erhitzen dann löst sich das
engagement auf
[Musik]
hierzu ist wieder schönen schlag kann
ich den kompletten zusammenführen also
es etwa quark in der große stiftung
richtet sich jetzt langsam die milch
erst mal nur ein bisschen wieder glatt
rühren und samen
und während den röhren merkt man auch
schon wie das akw das selbstwertgefühl
bereits bei 35 grad
größer und damit ein bisschen abkühlen
kurz an seite stehen aber wächst nur vor
sich immer beobachten
das ist die oberfläche nicht anfing zu
silieren und nehme jetzt meinen vertrag
einen chorus und abgekühlt und den sport
im rahmen der taufen herum habe jetzt
hier die zwei esslöffel pro telefon
überladene etwa marmelade ohne stützen
ohne kerne die schließlich in fintel auf
[Musik]
ich mache nicht mehr zu halten ist noch
immer ganz gerne egal was machen wenn
ich mit ihnen arbeite immer apropos
gefeierten klein bisschen gebe ich auf
dem teller und stört mich schon voraus
vor dem 5 und wenn ich merke jetzt kann
ich die sahne unterheben
[Musik]
und auch den eischnee und wer bringt
nochmal ein bisschen volumen mit fein
macht die ganze team etwas wochen
[Musik]
mit
die creme hier einfach vermögen gebracht
und zum glas greifen oder verteilen
könnte als komplex und her schaukeln
damit muss die schnitte im kühlschrank
für mindestens 4 stunden gekühlt werden
[Musik]
jacobellis gut durchgeführt und ich
werde jetzt wegen vor dem rahmen
[Musik]
und die heutige fuß leiten wird fünf mal
acht
[Musik]
aber bei den kugeln durch leider muss
man sich erst die partie entfernen
entweder dem anschneiden
[Musik]
vettel 45 fiel aufeinander
vielmehr ist gleich die kuvertüre
ardipithecus rauskommt findet man hier
[Musik]
habe ich hier 100 gramm peter gruppe
flügel bereits geschmolzen und
temperiert und gäbe es hier einfach ein
klassisches orchester proben damit sie
etwas geschmeidiger wird und später beim
schreiben nicht verklagt
[Musik]
und natürlich die kuvertüre in
spritzbeutel ohne team da kann man aber
auch noch für einen gefrierbeutel ganz
problem
[Musik]
leider sagt malik hiermit die kurz
vorher traum andreas
[Musik]
die kuscheligen fertig und konserviert
werden objekte unter den leider nicht da
ist dann ist er komponierte sie
probieren
lecker entwickelt
also ich merke fragt euch anscheinend
ganz und gar nicht gestellt
aber das müssen wir natürlich doch sehr
lecker wer möchte und gerne ein bisschen
frische kick mit reinbringen möchte halt
noch ein bisschen mit rundschau
abwickeln treiben sie mitunter auch
orange je nachdem wofür werden hat und
falls ihr dafür machen wollte und jedoch
verließ - noch ist die sind jedenfalls
richtig coole idee wohl vor allem zb
auch für die geburtstagsfeier gerade für
kleinkinder zum beispiel ist echt ne
hübsche und vor allem einfache idee also
viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
stützen uns nochmal wiederkommen stücke
zur nächsten mal
[Musik]